>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Well our next guest,
author Nathaniel Philbrick
is himself a history buff.
And he's written numerous
award winning books
about our nation's past.
Many of these including "In the
Heart of the Sea", "Sea of Glory"
and "Mayflower" reflect his life
long love of sailing and the sea.
Has anybody been sailing before?
His more recent books, "Bunker
Hill" and "Valiant Ambition" focus
on the events and figures
of the American Revolution.
In fact, the American
Revolution is the backdrop
for Nathaniel Philbrick's
first children's book.
"Ben's Revolution: Benjamin Russell
and the Battle of Bunker Hill".
School Library Journal describes
it as quote "A string account
of the American Revolution
sure to resonate
with elementary students"
-- end quote.
Nathaniel will be signing of
his books from 2:00 to 3:00
down in the signing area.
So without further ado
let's put our hands together
and welcome Nathaniel Philbrick.
[ Applause ]
>> Nathaniel Philbrick: Hello,
it is great to be here in D.C.
on this rainy day and great to
have you sitting around here.
And yeah, I write books
about history.
About things that actually
happened in America's past.
And "Ben's Revolution" is about
a boy who was 12-years-old
when the Revolution
broke out in Boston,
Massachusetts which
is actually the city
where I grew up, where I was born.
I was born in Boston.
But I actually grew up in a place
called Pittsburg, Pennsylvania.
[ Cheering ]
All right.
Some Steelers fans out there.
And it was when I was in
fifth great I read the book
that would really change my
life -- "Johnny Tremain".
[ Cheering ]
Yeah, we have some "Johnny
Tremain" lovers out there.
I mean this was a book about a
young boy who was apprenticed
as a silversmith, so he was making
beautiful silver bowls and platters
and things and he suffered
a terrible accident and so
that he couldn't be a silversmith
anymore and he got caught
up in the Revolution and became
a real important part of it.
And for me it was just amazing.
History wasn't about dates
and statues of old people,
it was about kids just
like me who --
ordinary kids who got caught
up in extraordinary events.
And this was just -- it like
-- I just couldn't believe it.
So that's back in my past
where people just like me.
And then I went to high school
and I had a great history
teacher named Miss Wilt,
who taught me about
American history.
We still exchange Christmas
cards every year.
And then in 1984 when I was almost
30 years old we moved to Boston
where the Revolution
broke out in 1775.
And by that time I had a year and
half old daughter named Jennie,
and I was at home taking care
of Jennie while her mother
was a lawyer keeping us going.
And we lived in the North End, which
is the historic center of Boston.
And it's just so cool.
It has all these crooked
streets and old houses.
Some of them look like
they're going to fall down.
And then I used to push Jennie's
stroller through the crooked streets
of the North End and we'd
always end up at the top
of this hill called Copp's Hill
where there was this really,
really old burial ground
where they had stones,
you know the old grave stones.
And you know what?
It was so old that these
grave stones were there
when the Revolution
broke out way back
in 1775, more than 200 years ago.
And some of these grave
stones had chips in them
from where British soldiers
who didn't like the politics
of whoever was buried there
fired on the gravestones.
And that was just amazing
to me to see a stone
that had been chipped way back in
1775 during the Boston Revolution.
And when you look out from Copp's
Hill you look across Boston Harbor
and there not too far away
on the other side is a place called
Charlestown and there is a monument,
a great big tall monument,
sort of a small version
of the Washington Monument that you
have here and it's where the Battle
of Bunker Hill was fought.
And Jennie and I would look out
at that and I began to wonder,
"What was Boston like back in
the time of the Revolution?"
And so every -- we developed
a routine where every Sunday,
I sort of had that day off and
Jennie's mom was taking care
of Jennie and I would get
on what is called the "T"
in Boston, it's the subway.
And I would go to the
Boston Public Library.
And you go into the
stacks and I was look --
what I wanted to find out what
was Boston like back then.
And I just learned some
amazing things that Boston,
the way it looks today was nothing
like Boston looked back then.
Now Boston looks like a city that's
all spread out, that has a bunch
of neighborhoods, there's
the Back Bay neighborhood,
there's Beacon Hill neighborhood.
But back in 1775, Boston
was an Island.
It was a 1.1 square mile island with
high hills, almost like mountains.
Three mountains dominating
this little island.
And then it had this very
narrow band of land that --
it was called the neck, that
connected this island to the town
of Roxbury, which was
on the mainland.
And so that was -- my gosh,
is that the way it was?
And across from the Boston
Harbor was then Charlestown,
which was a town on
it's own little island.
Now this got me to thinking.
It was for the first time --
back then I wrote about sailboats
and I started to say,
I'm really interested
in what it was like in the past.
My wife and I and Jeannie
and eventually her younger brother
Ethan, ended up moving to an island,
to Nantucket Island,
that's off of the south edge
of Cape Cod in Massachusetts.
And this island is
30 miles out to sea.
If you take a fairy that
has cars on it, it takes two
and half hours to get there.
And I was just fascinated
by this island and I said,
and this was the whaling capital of
the world back in the 19th Century
and so I started learning
about Nantucket's history
and I would ultimately
write my first book
about history about Nantucket.
But when i was researching
it I got all of that book,
I got all of these
stories about Boston
and the Revolution bubbling up.
Benjamin Franklin, have
you ever heard of him?
Yeah, yeah.
Benjamin Franklin's mother
was born on Nantucket.
And Benjamin Franklin, at the
time the revolution broke out was
in England trying to stop the
revolution from happening.
He was hoping that we could all --
that England and her
American colonies could figure
out a way to avoid a war.
But it didn't happen.
And he became one of
our foremost patriots.
And have you all heard
of the Boston Tea Party?
The Boston Tea Party?
OK, well there were three ships
in the Boston Tea Party that came
from England with tea that the king
wanted to sell to the colonists.
But the colonists were angry
because there was a tax that was --
they were going to be charged
if they bought the tea.
So what did they do?
They threw the tea -- they
took the tea off the ships
and threw it into the harbor.
And what did they call it?
Yes, the Boston Tea Party.
And in fact one boy who was
watching all this shouted out,
and this is in my book, "Boston
Harbor is a teapot tonight."
Well, two of those ships,
guess where they came from?
Nantucket Island.
They were whale ships that had
taken whale oil to England and then
on their way back put tea aboard
and it brought it back to sell --
and then got caught up
in the Boston tea party.
So I was going, wow I want to
write about the revolution.
And then, you know,
Nantucket is an island, right?
And we know Boston was an island.
And Boston back then
had 15,000 people in it.
That's a small, it's a small town.
Do you know how many people
live year round in Nantucket?
15,000. And I began to realize
after I lived on Nantucket
for a few years, you know if
you're living in an island
with 15,000 people you get to --
you may not know everyone's
name but you know them.
You know what they look like.
They're familiar to you.
And I began to realize that when
the Revolution broke out in Boston,
it was friends, neighbors,
acquaintances,
that suddenly you know
they used to work together
but suddenly their differences
meant that they didn't
like each other necessarily.
And the change that
created in a community,
I began to understand
in a very emotional way.
An then on Nantucket
we have a tradition
that many New England
towns still do.
It's called the town meeting.
Where to decide very big issues of
the day, everybody who is a voter
on Nantucket goes in -- we go
to our high school auditorium.
We have a town moderator who runs
the meeting and we vote on issues
that are very important to us.
And you here people
yell at each other.
You hear people praise each other,
but you know what this
-- this is democracy.
This is democracy being
enacted in a town.
And that's how the Revolution
in Boston began, was
with town meetings.
With people in town meetings
discussing the issues
of the day and, you know, those of
you who have been on the internet
and maybe know chat rooms.
Back in 18th Century Boston as the
Revolution was beginning to swell
across Massachusetts, those were
the chat rooms, the town meeting.
And I realized I've got
write about the Revolution.
So I would write a book
called "Bunker Hill".
I told you about the monument.
It's about the battle.
But it begins with the Boston
Tea Party and follows as --
because the British, once they heard
of the Boston Tea Party
they were very angry
and passed the Boston Port Act,
which closed the town
of Boston as a port.
It gave the people no way to
make money to support themselves.
And they sent a general,
a general Thomas Gage
to become their military governor
and the people were not happy.
And more and more soldiers
came to Boston.
And more and more people
who considered themselves
patriots left the town
until Boston became occupied
by 9,000 British soldiers.
That's a lot of British soldiers.
And the people who stayed in
Boston many of them were not happy
and there would be fights in
the streets and a lot of tension
until finally on April 19th, 1775
when Thomas Gage sent some soldiers
to the town of Concord to get the
cannons, and guns, and ammunition
that the patriots had
collected there.
He sent several hundred soldiers out
and on their way to Concord they had
to go to through the
town of Lexington .
And on the Green in Lexington
there were a whole line
of militiamen stood in their
way and guess what happened?
The first shot of the
Revolution was fired.
When we don't know if
it was a militiamen
or a British soldier but it started.
And then the British then went and
several militiamen were killed.
They then go to Concord and
then they have a big fight
at the old North Bridge
where more people are killed.
And then the soldiers have
to fight there way house
by house back to Boston.
And they get back to Boston, the
British close Boston to anybody
who is not on their side.
All of those militiamen who
were from every town crowd
into nearby towns of
Cambridge and Roxbury.
And suddenly Boston is a British
occupied city under siege.
At one point the British think
about trying to punch out
and attack the Americans.
But to stop them the
Americans decide
to build a fort on Bunker Hill.
They would get the wrong hill,
they'd actually do
it on Breed's Hill.
So it's a little confusing.
But it was by when the British
woke up on a June morning
and saw this fort, they decided
they were going to attack them.
And so they sent over
2,000 British soldiers
and boats across the harbor.
They rowed them across,
they off loaded
on to Charlestown, the peninsula.
And they marched up the
hill towards this fort,
which was full of patriot soldiers.
They thought they would be
able to take them very easily.
They were under General
Howe who was leading them.
They went up once and the
patriots stood their ground
and forced the soldiers back.
They went up twice.
Again the patriots held their
ground and forced the British back.
And a third time they went
up and the American's --
the militiamen ran
out of ammunition.
They could only fight the British
soldiers with their musket,
the butts of their muskets,
hitting them over the head
and they had to retreat.
And the British won the battle but
they had lost so many soldiers,
almost half their soldiers had
been either killed or wounded
that it was a British victory but
a moral victory for the Americans.
And now everyone in Boston, many
of whom had watched the battle
on the roofs of their houses.
This just happened a half
mile across the harbor.
It was like, you know, we watch
sometimes watch things on TV,
they were watching it from the
roofs of their houses and they knew
that the history of the country
and the world could
change with this battle.
And they realized this
was no longer a rebellion.
This was now a war.
A few weeks later George Washington,
you guys ever hear of him?
Yes. George Washington arrives
and takes charge of the Army.
And it will become
the Continental Army.
He conducts a siege for nine months
trying to get the British out.
A bookseller who becomes
the artillery --
head of artillery for the American
Army, Henry Knox brings cannons,
more than hundreds of miles down
from Lake Champlain to the North.
Those go on the high
ground overlooking Boston.
And the British realize
they have to leave.
And in March 1775 the British leave
and Washington has
knocked the British out.
The war would go on for many more
years but this was the beginning.
And it was researching
Bunker Hill I discovered
that there was a 12-year-old
boy named Benjamin Russell
who was good friends with the
newspaper man, Isaiah Thomas
and when the -- on the
day that Revolution broke
out on April 19th, he was in school.
They hear the Revolution, they
follow the British soldiers
who are sent out as reinforcements
off the island of Boston,
down the neck to Roxbury,
follow the soldiers
across the Charles
river to Cambridge.
They play in Cambridge,
having a great time,
and then they start hearing firing.
They hear the British Soldiers
coming back from Lexington
and Concord, fighting
their way back to Boston.
They go, "Oh my gosh, we better
get home to our parents in Boston."
But when they turn
to go back to Boston,
the British soldiers say, "Stop.
You cannot go back to Boston.
The war has begun."
And so Benjamin Russell
and his friends are trapped outside
Boston during the siege of Boston.
Benjamin Russell becomes
employed by the American army.
A Connecticut General, Israel Putnam
becomes his boss and he supplies,
helps supply food to the
soldiers who are digging earth
and forts around Cambridge.
And then on the day of Bunker Hill
he hears firing in Charlestown.
Israel Putnam rides
like crazy over there
and the Battle of Bunker
Hill unfolds.
Ben and his buddies go
up to Prospect Hill,
a high hill that overlooks
Bunker Hill
and Boston and watches the battle.
It's an amazing scene.
And this actually happened.
And then his father eventually
escaped from Boston, finds Benjamin
and apprentices -- he becomes
an apprentice to Isaiah Thomas,
the newspaper man who is now
in Worcester, Massachusetts.
Publishing the Massachusetts Spy,
Benjamin Russell will
one day become one
of the foremost newspaper
men in New England.
But it all began in the
American Revolution.
And I realized I have
to do a book about this.
So I decided to go with
"Ben's Revolution".
It tells his story.
And it was a wonderful --
writing this book was so much fun.
Trying to tell it to
young people and working
with the incredible
artist Wendell Minor.
And I want to -- I'm going to end
by reading a passage
from "Bunker Hill" OK?
Excuse me, from "Ben's Revolution".
OK it's the winter of 1775.
The British Soldiers
have arrived in Boston.
There's tensions with
the Boston citizens.
There's fighting in the streets.
The boys are not happy that
there are British Soldiers.
They go to the Boston Common, which
is still there if you go to Boston,
where the British soldiers are
practicing their maneuvers.
And they say, "Go home
you red coats!
Go home!" Well that winter
a storm comes and Ben
and his boys go sledding
and this is what happens.
This chapter is called
"Boy's Rights".
That January a storm
blew in from the North
and blanketed Boston in snow.
When classes were over at the
Queen Street Writing School,
where Ben was a student, he and
his friends got their wooden sleds
to go coasting down the
icy streets of Beacon Hill.
They started near the
mansion owned by the merchant
and patriot leader John
Hancock, pushing their sleds
across the rutted snow and ice until
they seemed to flying down the hill.
Ben was leading the pack as
they rushed down School Street
when suddenly his sled slowed down.
Ben was outraged to discover
that ashes had been spread
across the snow and ice to
make the street less slippery,
by the British officer who
had moved into a nearby house.
With several friends at his
side, Ben marched up the steps
of the British officer's
house and rapped on the door.
The officer was soon at the doorway.
Ben explained that for years this
as the boys' favorite coasting
place, and now it was ruined.
To Ben's surprise, the
officer ordered his servant
to pour water over the ashes.
Soon the water had frozen to ice,
and they were coasting once again.
Ben had been taught to believer
that the soldiers were in Boston
to take away his liberties.
But this officer had proven
to be an understanding man.
Later that night, the British
officer told General Gage
about his encounter with
Ben and his friends.
The general gave a weary sigh.
"No wonder we are having so much
trouble with these Bostonians,"
he said, "Even the children
insist on their rights."
And it actually happened.
You literally cannot
make this stuff up.
And so I realized i just
had to tell Ben's story.
And so Ben would be involved with
this sledding incident and I'm going
to end by reading when he learns of
the first shots of the revolution.
On the morning of April 19th, 1775,
Ben walked to the Queen
Street Writing School just
as he did everyday.
He and his friends were
sitting at their desks
when they heard the
sound of a Fife and Drum
on the street outside the school.
Master James Carter sent a boy
to find out what was happening.
He came back with amazing news.
The previous night General Gage
had sent 500 British soldiers
on a secret mission to seize the
cannons that the patriots had hidden
in Concord about 20 miles away.
But the mission had not
remained a secret for long.
By midnight, patriot riders like
Paul Revere, ever hear of him?
And William Dawes were headed out
of Boston to alert the countryside
that the British soldiers
were coming.
Each town in Massachusetts had its
own militia made up of patriots
who were willing to fight
for their families, farms,
and freedom when the
alarm was spread thousands
of them said goodbye to their wives
and children, took up their muskets
and powder horns and
headed to Concord.
But what the militiamen
have the courage to stand
up to the British soldiers.
At daybreak on the town
Green in Lexington,
the patriots showed
they had courage.
When the British soldiers charged
toward them the militiamen held
their ground.
The British fired their muskets
and eight militiamen were killed.
When Ben and his schoolmates
heard this they were stunned.
After more than a year of mounting
tension people, ordinary people just
like them had been shot
dead by British soldiers.
It now seemed that as if all hope
of settling matters peacefully
with the British were gone.
Master Carter looked
at them with a solemn
yet excited expression on his face.
Boys, he said -- and this
is true he said this --
"Boys, the wars begun
and you may run."
And thus begins the
adventure of Benjamin Russell
and the Battle of Bunker Hill.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.